qui dit été dit potager
ce résidant de saint lin laurentides
donne un peu d'eau à ses semis
l'arrosage de son jardin ou de sa
pelouse avec un boyau est pourtant
interdit les canayens qu'envoient les
arroser les canes maillet qui
depuis dix ans cette municipalité de
25000 habitants a connu une croissance
fulgurante qui a provoqué des problèmes
d'approvisionnement dès notre entrée à
pouvoir lors on a fait de ce dossier
lors la priorité absolue la pression
dans le réseau d'aqueduc est parfois
insuffisant pour prendre une douche si
bien que la ville fait venir de l'eau
par camion citerne le maire demande à la
population d'y mettre du sien on doit
avant le courage de dire aux gens que
s'ils arrosent leurs gosses comme ils
faisaient au courant des dernières
années et ça peut avoir des conséquences
ou une famille va pas avoir assez d'eau
par exemple en fin de journée pour laver
les jeunes enfants et la municipalité de
lanaudière n'est pas la seule à manquer
d'eau à saint lazare des nappes
phréatiques ont atteint un seuil
critique l'an dernier on peut voir
surtout dans la dernière fin de semaine
une consommation très axé l'arrosage est
permis quatre heures par semaine un
règlement apparemment contourner on voit
des pics au milieu de la nuit qui nous
indique que l'arrosage qui utilisent des
systèmes automatiques d'arrosage
un enjeu de plus en plus préoccupant à
québec le nombre de jours où l'on peut
arroser sa pelouse passe de 4 à 2 mais
il reste du travail à faire pour
convaincre
les citoyens de saint lin laurentides
sont invités à une grande rencontre
citoyenne demain la ville offrira des
solutions pour récupérer l'eau de pluie
par exemple mais je m'attaque demain les
yeux et les regards soient tournés vers
nous vacher ce que je voyais les ce qui
se passe ici pourraient survenir à peu
près n'importe où vous prévient le maire
de saint lin laurentides la sécheresse
sera la principale menace sur les
réserves en eau au québec dans les
prochaines années ici sébastien
desrosiers radio canada saint orens ty